Hohe Steuern, neueste Technologien und
eine ordentliche Portion Psychologie.
Das alles steckt hinter den Preisen für
vegane Pflanzendrinks.
Sebastian Lege erfährt in Schweden wie die Trendgetränke produziert werden
und zeigt euch, wie ihr sie zu Hause
günstig selber herstellen könnt.
Zur Herstellung pflanzlicher Milchalternativen braucht es Samen, Körner oder Nüsse -
und eine Maschine im XXL-Format.
SEBASTIAN: "Für meine Barista-Milchalternativen habe ich hier eine Mixer-Pyramide mit 12 PS."
Die Mixer sind der Schlüssel zur Herstellung von pflanzlichen Drinks.
Nur durch sie wird aus den Zutaten eine Art Kunstmilch.
SEBASTIAN: "Die Magazine sind geladen – jetzt kommt die Füllung."
Acht verschiedene Milchalternativen will Lege herstellen.
Dazu hat er die Nüsse und Körner mehrere Stunden in Wasser eingelegt.
SEBASTIAN: "Wir fangen an mit den Mandeln. Für einen Liter."
SEBASTIAN: "Soja!"
Von den teuren Grundzutaten nimmt Sebastian nur ganz wenig.
SEBASTIAN: "Haselnüsse. Da sind bei der Nussecke bei meinem Bäcker mehr drauf.“
"Macadamia. Jetzt wird es richtig exotisch."
"Cashew."
"Hafer."
"Hanfsamen."
"Riecht sehr neutral."
"Und zu guter letzt: Reis. Der günstigste Rohstoff von allen die hier auf dem Tisch stehen."
Insgesamt macht die Menge der Nüsse und Körner nur wenige Prozent der Rezeptur aus.
Der Hauptanteil ist: Wasser.
SEBASTIAN: "Genau ein Liter."
Damit bleibt der reine Warenwert enorm günstig.
Obwohl Lege alle Zutaten im Supermarkt
eingekauft hat -
die Kosten je Liter liegen im Centbereich.
Auch bei den Produkten im Handel ist von der Hauptzutat nur ein geringer Prozentsatz im Getränk.
Woher kommt dann der hohe Preis?
Die Zubereitung der kuhfreien Milch ist zumindest nicht sehr aufwendig.
SEBASTIAN: "Auf Knopfdruck: acht verschiedene Saaten und Nüsse melken.“
Mixer-Power Marsch!
Damit aus Wasser und Nüssen oder Körnern etwas Milchiges entsteht,
werden die Zutaten feinst zerhäckselt und vermengt.
„Der Milchersatz ist schon fertig, aber zum Aufschäumen reicht es noch nicht.“
Am Beispiel des Haferdrinks lüftet Lege
das Geheimnis hinter dem Schaum.
Erstmal filtert er die letzten Partikel heraus.
Genießbar wäre der Haferdrink jetzt schon,
doch fürs Aufschäumen fehlen noch Zutaten.
Auch hier nichts teures.
Lege greift zu bewährten Industriemitteln.
SEBASTIAN: "Ein bisschen Carrageen für die Bindung."
"Damit auch der gleiche Schmelz
entsteht wie bei einer Kuhmilch.“
Carrageen stammt aus Rotalgen und wird häufig als Gelier- oder Verdickungsmittel benutzt.
Jetzt noch Sojalecithin.
Das Pulver muss rein damit Leges
Kunstmilch mehr Fett aufnimmt.
SEBASTIAN: "Echte Kuhmilch hat natürlich Fett - unsere Hafermilch so gut wie gar nicht."
"Deswegen müssen wir ein wenig Öl hinzufügen,
um auch dementsprechend die Stabiltität in unserem Schaum hinzubekommen."
Sebastian greift zu Sonnenblumenöl.
SEBASTIAN: "Und fertig ist unsere
Barrista-Milchalternative."
Einfach, schnell und aus günstigen Zutaten hergestellt.
SEBASTIAN: "Super!"
Das Ergebnis kann sich sehen lassen!
Der Haferdrink lässt sich perfekt
aufschäumen.
SEBASTIAN: "Lecker."
Zusammengerechnet beläuft sich Sebastians Wareneinsatz für die Barista-Edition auf gerade mal 40 Cent.
Aber warum sind die Drinks im Handel dann so teurer?
In unserer Auswahl kosten alle über zwei Euro pro Liter.
Das will Sebastian bei einem der größten Haferdrinkhersteller weltweit erfahren.
Dafür fährt er nach Schweden.
SEBASTIAN: "Jawohl, da hinten ist es!"
"Boah, was für eine riesen Firma."
"Hello – my name is Sebastian, from the German Television."
"I will let you in."
- "Thank you."
Gut gesichert werden hier die Hafer-Drinks der Firma Oatly hergestellt.
Seit knapp einem Jahr gibt es die auch in deutschen Supermärkten
Zusammen mit Sebastian trifft auch eine neue Ladung Hafer ein.
EHLDE: "So wird der Hafer angeliefert."
Jeden Tag kommt ein LKW mit dem Rohstoff an.
SEBASTIAN: "So viel Hafer wird bei euch angeliefert?"
EHLDE: "In jedem Silo sind 40 Tonnen Hafer.
Unsere tägliche Umschlagmenge."
"So schnell wie der Markt wächst,
wird das bald noch mehr werden."
Fakt ist: Wer so viel Hafer einkauft,
erhält ordentlichen Mengenrabatt
und zahlt weitaus weniger für das
Getreide als Sebastian im Supermarkt.
Den genauen Einkaufspreis will uns
die Firma aber nicht verraten.
SEBASTIAN: "Oh wow!"
EHLDE: "Jetzt geht's rein in die Hafer-Fabrik"
8.000 Ein-Liter Packs laufen hier pro Stunde vom Band.
Verkaufsschlager ist der teure
Barista-Drink für über 2 Euro.
Doch was sagt die Firma dazu, dass Sebastians selbstgemachte Hafermilch
ihn nur 40 Cent pro Liter gekostet hat?
EHLDE: "Auch ohne zu probieren bin ich sicher, Sie haben einen tollen Hafer-Drink gemixt."
"Aber ohne unsere Technologie erreicht
der einfach nicht das gleiche Niveau."
Verglichen mit Milch sind Pflanzendrinks
noch Nischenprodukte.
Fabrikanlagen und Verfahren dafür
zu entwickeln, kostet Geld.
Das muss der Verkaufspreis wieder einspielen.
Außerdem gibt es Faktoren, die in
Sebastians Werkstattbilanz fehlten.
Amtliche Hygienestandards etwa
oder Verpackung und Transport.
Doch die gelten auch für Kuhmilch.
Wie erklärt die Firma Oatly den
immensen Preisunterschied?
EHLDE: "Anders als bei Milch gibt es für
unsere Branche keinerlei Subventionen."
"Und dann das deutsche Steuer-System: Da werden unsere Drinks als 'Getränke' mit 19 Prozent versteuert."
"Für Milch sind es nur 7 Prozent.
Das macht einen großen Unterschied."
Nachteil durch Subventionen?
Nach unseren Recherchen bezuschusst die EU inzwischen nicht mehr die Milch,
sondern Landwirte allgemein.
Auch der Hafer-Bauer erhält für jeden Hektar Ackerland Geld – wie der Milchbauer für seine Weiden.
Doch tatsächlich zahlen wir auf Milch mit 7% viel weniger Mehrwertsteuer als die 19% beim Haferdrink.
Und auch ein psychologischer Faktor schlägt zu Buche.
SCHAUTZ: "Diese Produkte sind
natürlich in, sind trendy, sind hip."
"Und für viele Verbraucher ist Milch
auch etwas nicht so Gutes."
"Sie wollen lieber auf etwas anderes zurückgreifen, und dafür sind sie bereit tiefer in die Tasche zu greifen.
"Und auch hier bestimmt natürlich die Nachfrage den Preis. Und die Verbraucher bezahlen gerne mehr.“
Hip-Faktor und cleveres Marketing
stecken also auch im hohen Preis.
"Ärgerlich für alle, die auf Milchalternativen angewiesen sind, wie Menschen mit Laktoseintolleranz.
Das sind schätzungsweise rund
15 Prozent der Deutschen.
Und nicht nur für die Drinks müssen Kunden tief in die Tasche greifen –
auch andere vegane Milchersatz-Produkte sind deutlich teurer als das Orginal von der Kuh.
In unserer Stichprobe kosten pflanzliche Joghurt-Ersatzprodukte um 35 Prozent mehr.
Frischkäsealternativen sind um 37 Prozent teurer.
Und Sahnealternativen sind 20 Prozent  teurer als milchhaltige Produkte.
Fazit: Die Industrie weiß, wie viel
Kunden bereit sind zu zahlen
und nutzt diese Bereitschaft gerne aus -
unabhängig vom Warenwert.
Was mögt ihr lieber im Kaffee:
Hafermilch oder Kuhmilch?
Sagt es uns in den Kommentaren!
Und wo es die besten
Lebensmittel gibt und was wirklich drin
steckt, zeigen wir euch auf unserem Kanal ZDFbesseresser!